the girag an experience I brought up
Quaker too so our church was you stand
up and speak and everyone just sits
there in silence yeah what's that like
which one's Quaker that's the oak box Oh
box everyone's like gets it confused
with Amish which doesn't nothing to do
with Amish the difference it's just a
very chill Christianity so it's those
the pilgrim hats the fist around Quakers
no I don't think they were the they were
when did Quakers and start I don't know
Sophists they're they're pacifists they
believe that God's in the form of an
inner light that's and everyone and
everything so why would you fight it I
mean I agree with that just from
hallucinogens and [ __ ] too but it's
something I struggle with like I have to
look back at you know childhood
predators and I'm like can I have to
forgive these people because they are
from the same light I guess what is the
what's the wacky thinkers Quakers are
well it's just very it's just you sit in
silence so the church's there's two
types there's programmed and unbroken
that was unprogrammed which is the super
chillin there's no Bible talk there's no
preacher there's nothing you just sit
and benches facing each other my meeting
house had these old creeps explain what
are you talking about so it's like a
it's a meeting house that you meet up
with on Sundays yeah you look down at
your hands you don't really look at each
other but you sit
there's facing benches and then there's
you know benches here so you are kind of
all looking at it you're facing each
other and what do you do you sit in
silence and then if you feel moved to
speak it supposed to be God speaking
through you but if you just feel moved
to speak at all you just stand up and
you say whatever you want Wow and so you
know reading scripture I mean some
people every once in a while someone
would do that growing up but I went to a
Quaker school too and we were little
kids we stuff to sit in signs for like
45 minutes which was impossible it's
such about 82 it was insane I would wear
shirts that had like things on it I
could play with like I had a shirt with
a phone and I had like a cord and I
would just wear it and I would set
alarms and set on my alarm so it
wouldn't go off I just had to be doing
stuff it was crazy
you're just so little and you're just
there's so bored I'm so bored you know
and what's the first thing they do they
try to medicate them because yeah
they're so bored well I got medicated to
just Ritalin and stuff
no but when I was older I don't feel
like it affected me they put me on
antidepressants a little bit but I was
pretty good at being like I don't want
to do these things you don't feel like
it affected you to be my Celyn but I
didn't take it for that long how long
did you take it for I don't know I don't
like looking for the home alley Makovsky
duh she was talking about what I love
her love her too she's just about how
like that same [ __ ] happened to her when
she was kids yeah bouncing off the walls
and the Medicaid yeah yeah it's so it is
interesting because it is I can only
imagine what it's like to be a parent
you just there's all this information
coming at you and you're dealing with
your own [ __ ] and a lot of people didn't
go through their healing process or
anything - so it must be so hard to be a
parent it's just got to be crazy I think
about it I never wanted to have a kid
until I did some hallucinogens and then
I was like maybe I want to have a kid
you'd be a great mom yeah I think I
would but I'm just dealing with all my
heel I'm dealing with all my I just want
to make sure I'm not in a place I I was
very angry in the past and it's
something that I work on a lot I just
wouldn't want to redo patterns and stuff
like that but I do think because I've
had I had such a traumatic stuff I think
I would be I think I could protect my
kids so good when the Quakers are
allowed to medicate their kids that's
part of the doctrine yeah you can so
there's no dot I mean it's pretty loose
it's like you can do whatever you want
there was one guy that wore his like
Jewish stuff to a meeting I went to
meeting after the election I went a
little bit I was like maybe I want to go
back to church what the Quaker Church
yeah I just fell in 16 yeah cuz I just
was it just triggered a lot of things in
me and and I went real crazy for a
second I just had a lot of trauma that I
wasn't doing one drop one it wasn't this
is embarrassing okay I was hanging out
with a lot of anyway what happened I
just got really like I got really mad I
don't know I got really mad I just
wasn't I wasn't um dealing with stuff
and it just kind of pushed all this
stuff forward for me and how so what do
you mean buddy just like some sexual
assault stuff just came up like I think
a lot of people that were angry and were
marching around and stuff we had some
personal triggers that had happened for
them so because of like the grab him by
the [ __ ] - yeah and then you read it
and then I read up on it and it's not
what it seems and I don't know I just I
you know there was a lot of hysteria and
it just triggered just triggered a lot
of my [ __ ] but I'm glad it did because
it helped me get through a lot of stuff
and I definitely I think have a
different view on those things now and I
you know I was running around so mad at
who I'm like Who am I mad at I did a lot
of like when it first happened I was
like [ __ ] man I did that for about three
months thank God I got out of that but
really angry and just projecting and
piss and all this stuff and it's like
there's a few there's a few men I'm mad
at right there's a few I'm certainly not
mad at men but there are a few from your
past yeah you know and that was
something I had to deal with and I had
to learn to compartmentalize that and
not make it this broad thing I hate when
people use upsetting the drinking days
the drinking days and for my childhood
you know I had I had some [ __ ] up
should happen but you know it it's you
can't it's just important for me to not
blame a large group of people that have
nothing to do with my trauma and it's
also when I get triggered what I needed
to learn was that's my responsibility to
handle my trigger and I can't just be
running around like this like unsheath
sword
I mean I can but I'm gonna cut everyone
around me yeah the thing that people do
when they blame everyone that's part of
that group you know it's so common it so
you remember there was a real problem a
few months back where Liam Neeson was
talking about one of his friends that
had gotten something that happened were
black I had done something murdered one
of his friend
raped when I was friends something awful
thing right and so he would go out at
night with a bat looking for a black guy
to start trouble and he talked about and
everybody was furious at him yeah and he
was saying like look I didn't do
anything and I was in a terrible state
of me I'm just being honest about this
I'm not proud it was one of the most
embarrassing and darkest my life but I
did it right and not letting people
express those things and and talk about
it and say oh wait because I am
embarrassed that I got so man Haiti I
mean it's invite you know there's a
couple podcast I did where I was like
[ __ ] man you know and I that hurts
people I hurt people by saying that I
mean for whatever No
but people have lashed out at me for
stuff like that but it's like I don't
[ __ ] I don't have the capacity to hate
an entire group of people and I
certainly like I have brothers I have my
dad I don't don't you think so sometimes
you say things and that's not really
what you mean yeah pressing anger mm-hmm
of course and then I think right now
what's going on and I've checked out of
a lot of stuff I don't pay attention to
a lot of things anymore because it was
just like what the news you mean yeah
it's just like not it's not real I don't
read Twitter at all I just don't do it
it's like I got to focus on what I can
do and how I can feel good and how I can
I just want to make people laugh have a
good time make people feel good I want
to feel good it's like I can't do that
if I'm in this constant state of taking
and all this information that's just
pushing my buttons pushing my buttons
well yeah some of its not gonna be but
someone certainly is and you if you're
not controlling the like you have a
mental diet too and that's something
that people don't think of all the time
you know I remember who described it
that way but it's the best way of
describing it you have a physical diet
and if you have a poor physical diet
your body set yeah but if you have a
poor mental diet your mind is sick yeah
you're taking a nonsense all talk and
fights
[Applause]